YouTube law states that you can't do a
video about fifty shades of gray without
wearing fuzzy pink handcuffs or some
other non-threatening bachelorette party
level signifier of kink that
inadvertently captures the dissonance
between intensity of the marketing
around fifty shades of gray as some
really taboo pushing kink and the actual
product anyway here's a lukewarm defense
of the first movie the following program
deals with issues of intimate partner
violence and abuse viewer discretion is
advised
alright history lesson master of the
universe is a 2009 through 2011 serial
Twilight fan fiction written by Erica
Mitchell under the pen name snow Queens
ice dragon and collected into two
volumes in this alternate universe Bella
Swan is a university student who falls
into the orbit of vampy but not actually
a vampire billionaire Edward Cullen
after interviewing him for the school
paper the relationship rapidly and
clumsily escalates with Edwards stalking
Bella kidnapping her revealing his deep
dark secret that he's really into some
Spanky stuff then they go back and forth
with Bella being alternately scared and
intrigued and repeat for about 700 pages
with a couple stalker subplots and
helicopter crash sprinkled into the back
half and that gets you to the end of
part 1 where Edward asks Bella to marry
him the final chapter ending on a
cliffhanger where an unnamed character
swears his revenge on the Cullens as he
watches them from across the lake in
part two Bella and Edward get married
and accidentally pregnant Edwards sister
Alice's kidnapped by Bella's former boss
one of the stalkers from the previous
volume Bella pays the ransom and shoots
the guy in the leg Edward is like fine
whatever their kid is born the end I
guess happily ever after they move into
a really really big house but keep the
downtown condo as a dedicated sex den on
a structural level master of the
universe is an alternate universe all
human retelling of Twilight so it
doesn't claim to take place in a
contiguous universe with the original
novels and the supernatural elements
have been removed while the story itself
remains largely the same just adapted
for the new gimmick in this case Bella
being a university student
and Edward being a billionaire who likes
to be brunette girls that look like his
birth mother I'm a sadist Bella I like
to whip little brown haired girls like
you because you all look like the crack
[ __ ]
my birth mother still it follows
Twilight's plot across the broad strokes
Bella is pushed into a scenario where
she beats Edward they have some
back-and-forth
Edward saves Bella from an accident they
start a relationship after Edward
reveals his dark secret there's a dinner
with Edwards family and the whole thing
culminates in a moment where Edward goes
too far with his dark secret as a serial
fanfiction master of the universe was
published first in pieces on
fanfiction.net and starting in early
2010 Mitchell began parallel publishing
raunchy versions on her personal site
Fifty Shades calm within the scope of
fanfiction.net the story was a genuine
hit attracting an estimated 16 to 20
thousand readers at a very high level of
engagement with people collectively
leaving thousands of comments and
reviews in addition to talking about it
on forums and sharing it on their blogs
this engagement was further lubricated
by Mitchell's aggressive publication
speed and her accessibility chapters
were often coming out every two days for
several weeks at a stretch pushing the
story to the front page of recently
updated stories and I see as she was
called within the community was quick to
pick fights with negative reviews and
heaped praise on positive ones
this type of spiraling engagement forms
a feedback loop where readers see this
story with thousands of comments
amid stories with dozens and feel
compelled to be in the know to find out
what this thing is that everyone is
talking about the novel Fifty Shades of
Grey
written by Erica Mitchell under the pen
name L James was published in May 2011
by the writers coffee shop an australian
boutique publisher focused on turning
fanfiction into commercial literature it
is a lightly edited version of roughly
the first half of master of the universe
part one where the names have been
changed and where Cullen is now
Christian Grey and Bella Swan is now
Anastasia Steele when I say lightly
edited I do mean lightly for example
Christian now spends 43 dollars at an a
store rather than the fifty three
dollars
Edwards spent at Bella's and these
ellipses are now common
yes yes there's more changes than that
if you want to go by absolute number
there's a lot of changes thousands even
wants to include punctuation but it's an
understatement to even say that the core
of the two is the same the two texts
side by side read almost the same with
really only a minor pass for rewording
the plot and general structure remains
untouched due to Mitchell's existing
passionate fan base and landing right at
the time when ear eaters were really
breaking into the mainstream the e-book
of 50 shades was released to strong
initial sales sending it to the top of
the bestsellers list and priming a
similar feedback loop where more and
more people pick it up and start talking
about it in order to be in the know
about the thing that everyone is talking
about the feedback loop was further
compounded by the remainder of master of
the universe being published in
September 2011 and January 2012 as fifty
shades darker and fifty Shades freed
with both books seeing similarly strong
sales in addition to engagement both
positive and negative on the social
cataloging site Goodreads with multiple
erotica books from the same series on
the best sellers list media quickly
picked up on it as a curiosity further
boosting its profile by the end of 2011
the Fifty Shades books has sold around
250,000 copies and drawn the attention
of major publishers after a short
bidding war vintage an imprint of Random
House now penguin Random House acquired
the publication rights in March 2012
releasing the entire trilogy as
mass-market paperbacks in April 2012
flooding bookstores around the globe and
cementing Fifty Shades as a genuine
cultural phenomenon in May 2013
Universal and Focus Features acquired
the film rights for approximately 5
million US and production began on the
big-screen adaptation of the trilogy to
be directed by Sam taylor-johnson
starring Dakota Johnson as Ana and Jamie
Dornan as Christian with the first film
slated for release Valentine's Day
weekend 2015 now the books are well
they're pretty bad but I want to cut a
fine line here there's a lot of
criticism that has come at Fifty Shades
from a lot of different angles some
valid and some distinctly less valid so
for example
the prose and the dialogue are pretty
abysmal this is valid criticism the
serial nature of the original
publication is something that was never
worked out in the editing process so
plot threads will abruptly end the story
will get sidetracked in a random aside
for several chapters at a time that will
ultimately be dropped in forgotten
things are rarely foreshadowed and at
least one character this integral to the
plot link is only mentioned in passing
like four times in the entire series and
never actually shows up it needs to be
acknowledged as with its origin as an
alternate universe retelling of Twilight
and having seen so few alterations
during editing Fifty Shades falls into
some serious gray areas of plagiarism
beautiful the skin of a killer book
I mean Fifty Shades has eight Twilight
all the way down to the cover design and
shortly after Stephenie Meyer scuttled
plans for Midnight Sun a version of
Twilight told from Edwards point of view
Mitchell announced her plans to retell
Fifty Shades from Christians point of
view
well Meyer has refrained from litigating
anything about the relationship between
Twilight and Fifty Shades Mitchell's
lawyers have not been so magnanimous and
kind cracking down heavily on derivative
works that capitalize on the popularity
of Fifty Shades describing them as
parasitic this is itself an extension of
Mitchell's willingness to pick fights
with critics down to starting petty
arguments with people on Twitter the
story also via bella / anna's running
internal commentary perpetuates dominant
cultural narratives that pressure women
to take responsibility for the abuse
that their intimate partners inflict on
them and much of the interaction between
the leads is more than a little hazy in
the area of consent in a way that many
critics find to be not merely
controversial but disingenuous and even
dangerous now without getting too deep
into the weeds I want to acknowledge
that fantasy fiction erotic fiction
playing with ideas and scenarios that
blur the lines of consent or even step
right over them are strictly
illegitimate as subject matter
most of our fiction involves scenarios
that we would never want to actually
experience whether that be getting
caught in a gunfight or trapped at a
cabin in the
with a killer and the idea that some
people find non-consensual sexual
scenarios thrilling is maybe not as
weird as it's often painted Christine
loves a visual novel Ladykiller in a
bind is a text that delves quite far
into scenarios of dubious consent for
the purpose of both titillating and
challenging the audience it is an
experience that can get rough at times
pun intended
playing through one scenario left me
with a lingering sense of betrayal that
took several days to fully process the
game opens however with a reminder that
fiction is a means for people to explore
ideas and scenarios in ways that are
safe or at least safer in a videogame
you effectively have the ultimate safe
word you can exit the program at any
time and it will stop instantly it's
like the fuzzy pink handcuffs they're
not real they're just toys they look and
behave close enough to real handcuffs
but the key is just for show it's
actually less convenient than just using
the lever in most situations someone
wearing them can pretty effortlessly get
themselves out they are a form of
performative fiction they are the
illusion of danger they are a safer way
to explore the sensation of restraint of
loss of control but that isn't to say
that they are truly safe you can still
wear them too tight you can still ignore
warning signs and you can still end up
in an awful position that does lasting
damage
similarly fiction provides us a way to
explore ideas and scenarios that would
be hazardous traumatizing or both in
real life fiction is a way to practice
intense emotional States but that
doesn't make fiction harmless it still
impacts us and indeed impacting us is
the entire point this is why critics
argue that the subject of fictional non
consent can still be handled more or
less ethically an issue that comes down
to framing something that Fifty Shades
routinely fails at and fails hard it's
not merely that master of the universe
in Fifty Shades wander into areas of
dubious consent it's that Erika Mitchell
as a writer doesn't seem to be entirely
aware that that is the territory that
she's in in a synergy of failings
mitchell has responded aggressively to
critics raising this point
including one delightful incident where
she angrily tweeted at a rape survivor
criticizing the way Christian treats Ana
quote no rape in Fifty Shades with the
attached gift
hashtag read the book critics within the
BDSM and King communities have
additionally focused on the books bad
and unhealthy representation of kink
dynamics and the way that it presents
kink as something that people get into
only because they have serious
unresolved issues with past abuse these
two veins of criticism merge into the
synthesis criticism that Fifty Shades of
Grey does not depict either a healthy or
unhealthy kink lifestyle but routine
domestic abuse being masked as tank with
critics pointing to the many ways the
Christian works to undermine Ana's
mental well-being her sense of stability
and her ability to consent he negotiates
their sex contract while plying her with
alcohol isolates her physically and
emotionally from friends and family
belittles her interests mocks her sexual
inexperience regularly leaves her in
tears makes her financially dependent on
his approval and constantly reminds her
of both his vast wealth and his
willingness to use it to monitor and
pursue her in a 2012 interview with
books in Review Mitchell responded to
such criticism with this noting freaks
me out more than people who say this is
about domestic abuse bringing up my book
in this context trivializes the issues
doing women who actually go through it a
huge disservice
it also demonizes loads of women who
enjoy this lifestyle and ignores the
many many women who tell me they found
the book sexually empowering so it is
fair to say that Mitchell herself does
not see the parallels believes that she
has crafted a fair if fantasized version
of a kink lifestyle and has been openly
resentful of critics who insist
otherwise however even with all these
criticisms it needs to be acknowledged
that a huge chunk of the backlash to
Fifty Shades stemmed from and manifested
as rampant misogyny and an assault on
the public visibility of female
sexuality and sexual agency with many
many people using legitimate criticism
as a springboard to mock mommy porn in
the very idea of women finding anything
erotic if it didn't conform to strict
male centric ideas of feminine sexuality
in this context it's not even weird to
consider that a certain component of 50
success can be attributed to a
collective political act of defiance
women publicly embracing the book not
for its quality or even because it
suited their tastes but because of what
its success represents in a culture that
generally sees pornography for women as
both setup and punchline
so before we start really digging into
the meat of Fifty Shades failings I do
want to take a moment to talk about what
resonated with audiences the books
aren't good but it's disingenuous to
insist that no one could then engage
with them authentically it has clearly
struck a chord with its core audience
and developed a loyal fan base that
likes it for what it is in whole or in
part the first unavoidable connection is
as fan fiction which is where the
earliest fans came on board they weren't
reading an original construct but an
explicit derivative one of the
advantages and indeed one of the
foundational appeals of fan fiction is
the ability to shortcut to the good
stuff because so much about the
characters and the world is able to be
presupposed this also as a side note
often leaves fan fiction with thumb
prints all over it as the opening
chapters of an alternate universe story
are going to be largely devoted to
getting the audience caught up on the
deviations from the core they are
already familiar with this is why Fifty
Shades for example calls explicit
attention to Ana getting drunk for the
first time it's an explicit deviation in
Bella's character as written in Twilight
but there's this appeal to seeing
characters that the audience has already
formed a parasocial bond with in
synthesized scenarios and novel
circumstances this isn't even all that
odd outside the realm of fan fiction DC
comics over the years has imagined
Batman as a vampire as a pirate as a
medieval knight and as an 18th century
detective chasing Jack the Ripper
just to name a few of the literally
dozens of alternate universe Batman that
are out there at a certain point
characters cease to require their
context to be whole and in fact become
their own context and subsequently the
fun comes from taking them and moving
them around playing with them in a
variety of different styles and
scenarios in this way fanfiction is the
literary evolution of childhood play
taking disparate toys and bringing them
to
other an almost instinctive exercise and
creative synthesis it is not a mystery
that fanfiction appeals to so many
because it is naturally what stories
pursue the meeting point between the
familiar and the unexpected moving
beyond the fanfiction many fans enjoy
indulging in the economic fantasy the
thrill of absurd wealth and privilege
the story about an ordinary girl plucked
out of obscurity by an incomprehensible
rich dude who is able to give her
virtually anything that she wants indeed
elements that many critics have found
odd or infuriating are to the invested
reader part of the appeal Ana rejects
Christians gifts which he then imposes
on her this allows the reader to indulge
the dual fantasy of maintaining a sense
of social propriety the self-perception
of being the person who was humble
down-to-earth and proper while still
enjoying all the material benefits of
dating a man with more money than an
individual could ever spend
also we shouldn't leave it merely
implied many people enjoy the
pornography they find the sexual
dynamics and writing authentically
erotic that may seem unbelievable
because the writing is so often just
painful but what do we benefit
critically for pretending that no one
could sincerely enjoy the material
conversely simply because people enjoy
it authentically doesn't mean that
criticism of the material either in
terms of technique or subject matter
become invalid critical readings of
Fifty Shades the document patterns of
abuse how Christian isn't merely
dominant domineering or even just an
[ __ ] but works to tear down anna
coerce her intentionally confound her
ability to consent and isolate her
socially these are still valid and
important readings even if there's an
audience that finds it sexually
stimulating so with all that in mind
what's wrong with Fifty Shades of Grey
well a lot a big thing that I want to
talk about because it's going to be the
most relevant later is the legacy of
serialization this is an issue that
compounds as the books go on but it's
significant pretty much right out of the
gate in particular the serial fanfiction
method tends towards a sort of public
performance alright
might publish a short dead end a chapter
purely because they haven't posted
anything in a few weeks and their fans
are wondering if the Fick is dead ideas
might catch the author's attention but
after a few weeks they decided just
isn't going the direction they or the
audience want and so the plot thread is
abandoned because the nature of serial
fiction is to always keep pushing
forward and edits are only made
chapter-by-chapter these problems then
persist into further derivatives for
fifty shades of gray and specific these
mostly manifest as a lot of cyclical
repeating scenes in the middle of the
book petty arguments and conflicts that
happen often enough that it's hard to
remember which specific one was in which
specific chapter and numerous side
stories that last a chapter or two
before abruptly ending now ideally these
are exactly the kind of issues that an
editor would address in adapting a fan
fiction from forum thread to publish
novel and this is as good a time as any
to mention that Erica Mitchell is by all
accounts absolutely awful to work with
reportedly the first editor she was
assigned at the writers coffee shop
tasked with turning master of the
universe into Fifty Shades was removed
from the project after a Mitchell
complained that she was trying to make
too many changes to the structure of the
books that kind of behavior is going to
come up again when we're talking about
the movies and she's spending an hour on
set screaming at the director over
changes to dialogue speaking of the
dialogue it's it's not good I'm going to
lump Anna's internal monologue in with
this because the words characters say
aloud and the things Anna thinks to
herself tend to play off each other in
the worst way I could always take them
off he smirks um I feel the color in my
cheeks rising again I must be the color
of the Communist Manifesto stop talking
stop talking now I was in the area he
says by way of explanation I need to
stock up on a few things it's a pleasure
to see you again miss Steele his voice
is warm and husky like dark melted
chocolate fudge caramel or something
what's vanilla sex
I asked if anything to distract myself
from the intense burning
see look he's giving me he laughs just
straightforward sex Anastasia
no toys no add-ons he shrugs you know
well well actually you don't but that's
what it means oh I thought it was
chocolate fudge brownie sex that we had
with a cherry on top but hey what do I
know
Mitchell also has an awkward habit of
juxtaposing erotic imagery with
infantilizing internal commentary from
Anastasia Anna is seemingly perpetually
confused by the world around her and
naive to the point of farce a thread
that persists all the way to the very
end of the trilogy
lastly Mitchell doesn't have a deft
touch when it comes to managing the
sexual danger again because she is or at
least publicly performs being completely
unaware and in denial that her writing
steers into areas of dubious consent
there are many many moments where Anna
is legitimately afraid of what Christian
might do to her to quote romance author
Jenny trout on the issue while there is
something of a thrill factor in having
the heroine be a little afraid of the
super alpha hero you have to walk a
really delicate balance you don't want
the reader to think that the heroine is
actually super afraid of the hero or
that she has a reason to find him
literally dangerous because that's when
the fear stops being sexy this is for
many readers a source of much of their
frustration the book doesn't manage to
balance sexy danger but it also refuses
to embrace the danger danger that it
creates there is a potentially
legitimately decent erotic thriller or
even erotic horror somewhere inside the
subject matter but Erika Mitchell seems
convinced that living in constant fear
of your sexual partners temper is just
what a kinky sex life looks like and
yeah I think that's enough context to
start talking about the movie
50 shades of gray is a 2015 film written
by Kelly Marcel and directed by Sam
taylor-johnson based on the 2011 novel
of the same name in this project the two
women were given the task of wrangling a
trashy BDSM erotica novel full of clumsy
plot abusive threadbare characters and
awful dialogue into a sellable movie so
I'm gonna start this off with the
admission that I actually kind of like
the first Fifty Shades movie not because
it's any good but because there's a
certain creative Verve to it like the
filmmakers were actually trying really
hard to capitalize creatively on this
momentary zeitgeist rather than simply
cashing in and riding the money train
through three basically guaranteed jobs
there's a dynamic around the first film
that I found compelling particularly how
it was cast in many circles as the worst
film of the year when really it was just
fairly middling as someone who has read
the source material I was largely
entertained by mentally cataloging all
the points where the film had managed to
improve on the source material coming
frustratingly close to making it
actually kind of good or at least trashy
fun if I took bits and pieces only
showed you the best clips I could
probably put together a convincing
argument that this is actually a really
good film director Sam taylor-johnson
and screenwriter Kelly Marcel both
publicly clashed with Mitchell over the
course of the project and in both cases
the conflict revolved principally around
changes to the source material this is
ironic because the source material is
easily the worst thing about the movie
this is also the thing where well I mean
the whole thing was ultimately doomed in
the deal with Universal and Focus
Mitchell retained a massive amount of
creative control with something nearly
approaching total veto power over any
creative decision and well if her books
are any indication creativity isn't her
strong suit still the film diverges
subtly but substantially from the book
the middle of the story has been cleaned
up and more or less sorted out scenes
have been merged deleted had their
locations changed lots of small
adaptational stuff a huge change and his
inner monologue has been dropped and
tired
while she is still the point of view
character with the camera rarely cutting
away two scenes that she's not in she is
no longer than narrator this has
substantial and far-reaching impacts on
both the general tone and reading of the
story but particularly on Anna's
character double crap me and my 2 left
feet Kelly holy cow he's so young
if this guy's over 30 then I'm a
monkey's uncle Christian gray holy crap
what the hell is he doing here
looking all outdoorsy with his tousled
hair and in his cream chunky knit
sweater jeans and walking boots I
thought it was you what a pleasant
surprise miss Steele I'm not gonna touch
you not until I have your written
consent what does that mean does he
white slave small children to some
godforsaken part of the planet is he
part of some underworld crime syndicate
it would explain why he's so rich is he
deeply religious is the impotent surely
not he could prove that to me right now
anna is generally made more competent
and proactive simply by excluding all
the times in the book where something
will happen and her inner monologue will
comment on how she doesn't understand
what's going on or what people are
talking about movie anna is a lot more
confident funnier emotionally aware and
less of a swooning catastrophe and the
movie cuts out the dozen or so times
that small interactions with Christian
leave her a sobbing wreck she also
doesn't complain endlessly in her head
about her friends and is quicker to put
her foot down when Christian gets out of
line it is left to the audience to
extrapolate from Dakota Johnson's acting
exactly how comfortable and safe they
think Anna is in any given scene as a
further consequence of moving the point
of view out of Anna's head it
dramatically alters the abusive elements
of the book and this in turn ties into
changes to Christian who as a character
has been softened to be a bit more
natural and less volatile he doesn't
scream at people he doesn't beret
constantly for her eating habits he
doesn't talk constantly about wanting to
possess her he's just a bad kind of
needy boyfriend that's still not good
but it means there's at least something
likable about the movie Christian where
book Christian is cruel capricious and
constantly on the edge of violence I'll
just make a call I murmur I just want to
hear Kate's voice he frowns the
photographer his jock punches and his
eyes burn I blink at him I don't like to
share
miss Steele remember that his quiet
chilling tone is a warning and with one
long cold look at me he heads back to
the bedroom holy crap I just wanted to
call Kate I want to call after him but
his sudden aloofness has left me
paralyzed what happened to the generous
relaxed smiling man who was making love
to me not half an hour ago and this is a
good point to mention that it's kind of
okay if Christian is a garbage person
like from a narrative standpoint it's
not bad that Christian is bad that he's
a bad person or a bad boyfriend it's a
story it's drama we want conflict we
want some volatility and excitement and
even a level of emotional intensity that
would be exhausting in real life but is
fun to pretend with for a few hours
him being a bad boyfriend a poor
communicator emotionally distant
these give the characters things to
conflict over things for them to clash
against generating tension drama and
story to take an example from later in
the film Christian spanks Anna in a way
that the film plays as playful there's a
lot of good tension in the scene with
Anna's conflicting desires and yeah
Dakota Johnson has played the scene as
Anna realizing that she kinda likes it
and then Christian up and leaves and
Anna being abandoned starts to break
down from the intensity of it this is
actually really good drama it's
presented as not any one thing but the
aggregate combination of the intensity
and Christians emotional unavailability
is left to the viewer to decide just how
far they think Anna thinks Christian has
gone what has been removed are the pages
of internal monologue where Anna feels
like she's being assaulted but
rationalizes it away
because of how much she loves Christian
I stare down at my hands what can I say
that I haven't said already I want more
I want him to stay because he wants to
stay with me not because I'm a
blubbering mess and I don't want him to
beat me is that so unreasonable this is
how book Anna
consistently frames the encounter she
doesn't process it as play but as abuse
and Christian dismisses her concerns out
of hand so you felt demeaned debased
abused assaulted
how very tess durbeyfield of you I
believe it was you who decided on the
debasement if I remember correctly do
you really feel like this or do you
think you ought to feel like this two
very different things if that is how you
feel do you think you could just try to
embrace these feelings deal with them
for me that's what a submissive would do
again this isn't from a story
perspective strictly bad in isolation it
is a source of conflict but the real
world implications are troubling and the
conflict is never confronted or properly
resolved Christian just tells Anna to
get over it that if she really loved him
should be a good submissive and just
deal with it and that friction never
becomes part of book Anna's motivations
moving on the entire opening of the film
is a great case study in the difference
in skill and craft between the original
and the filmmakers the opening montage
is actually really good
lots of good leading lines lots of well
juxtaposed shots and parallels it sets
the color palette the musical tone the
visual pace it's really solid filmmaking
fundamentals this shot of Anna looking
up at grey house where it's all slanted
because it's putting her off-kilter
is great judicious use of a Dutch angle
that also helps fit a very tall building
into a narrow frame using visuals to
contrast Anna and Christian is a much
better introduction to the two
characters than they get in the book
where they don't even really have one
because they're clearly Bella and Edward
who you already know because you dear
fanfiction reader have
read all of Twilight twice first I don't
make love I [ __ ] hard a significant
alteration to the interview is injecting
a bit of awareness of the lameness of
the interview as written in the book
where Anna asks a series of banal and
low-key insulting questions that
Christian just answers one after the
other there's a bit of verbal sparring
but it's overwhelmingly the kind of
utilitarian information dump that serves
to get the fan fiction reader up to
speed on the new rules of the story's
universe the filmmakers wisely discard
most of this and plant two moments in to
acknowledge that the interview kinda
sucks you are very young to have amassed
such an empire to what do what do I owe
my success yep but then unfortunately
the source material comes crashing back
in are you gay alright okay okay let's
pause for a bit so this is as good a
time as any to mention the shades of
homophobia and misogyny that lay over
master of the universe and all
subsequent derivatives in the books
given that the reader is privy to all of
Anna's thoughts it becomes obvious
almost comical how almost every man and
woman that Anna comes across is
evaluated as a possible sexual
competitor particularly relevant to this
scene Christian staffs his office
exclusively with hot blonde women and
tight skirts and blazers and Anna starts
to refer to them throughout the books as
the Stepford blondes Anna's blonde
roommate Kate also falls into a
relationship with a billionaire starting
a fling with Christians brother Elliot
that also evolved over the course of the
books into marriage and babies but Kate
is subject to endless internal criticism
for doing well pretty much exactly what
Anna is doing Elliot grins and pulls
Kate into his arms where she is more
than happy to be Kate even in my
inebriated state I am shocked she only
just met him then there's the gay thing
are you gay there's a character a
masseuse dropped from the movies that
the books go to comical lengths to point
out that he's gay totally gay super gay
definitely gay and thus allowed to be
around Anna
when Christian isn't there then of
course there's this which somehow made
it all the way through the adaptation
process including the even stranger
companion line from later where Anna
spreads the rumor to undercut two of her
classmates that she overhears talking
about how cute her secret boyfriend is
I'm actually at a complete loss as to
why that's there however bad is this
question maybe it does lead into a great
example of how much better the film is
than the novel in the book Anna and
Christian are sitting on a large couch
for the entire interview they just sit
down and talk and talk and eventually
the time for the interview runs out when
one of the blondes comes in and tells
him his next meeting is almost ready to
start but Christian cancels it the
lead-in to Christian canceling the
meeting is Anna telling Christian that
Kate is sick did you volunteer to do
this interview he asks his voice deadly
quiet hang on who's supposed to be
interviewing whom his eyes burn into me
and I'm compelled to answer with the
truth I was drafted she's not well my
voice is weak and apologetic that
explains a great deal there's a knock at
the door and blonde number two
enters mr. gray forgive me for
interrupting but your next meeting is in
two minutes we're not finished here
Andrea please cancel my next meeting in
contrast here's how the movie handles
the same transition point in the
conversation what about you
why don't you ask me something that you
want to know earlier you said that there
are some people who know you well why do
I get the feeling that that is not true
mr. grey your next meeting is in the
conference for council please we're not
finished here
yes sir so first of all we're working
with visual levels Christian spends most
of the scenes standing over Anna a
straightforward power position but with
the turning point he moves to the chair
brings himself down to Anna's level so
we have some visual power play second
rather than leading into Christian
canceling the meeting with a banal point
about Kate being sick it's a pointed
question from Anna that is actually
disarming this question paraphrased why
do I get the feeling no one knows the
real you
piques his interest it creates an
honest-to-god emotional exchange
Christian invites Anna to test him even
disarms himself a little as part of his
game and she cuts right through his
facade I just wonder if perhaps your
heart might be bigger than you want to
let on well this question also makes
Anna into a far more emotionally
intelligent character than she is in the
novel's movie Anastasia sees right
through most of Christians games where
the novel version of this exchange is
predatory Christian manipulating the
largely oblivious Anna the film version
has Christian attempting to toy with
Anna and being caught off guard by her
response this is part of a pattern in
the film where Anna has been injected
with a lot of much needed narrative
agency this one line for example
actually represents a huge change to
Anna's character verses the novel's the
scene is from chapter 3 of the book and
in the book the whole process of
negotiating going for coffee takes a
page and a half of arguing the logistics
of who is going to drive Jose and his
assistant home because Anna doesn't
actually want to go or she's not sure if
she wants to and maybe she wants to but
she kind doesn't I wondered if you would
join me for coffee this morning my heart
slams into my mouth a date
Christian Grey is asking me on a date
you haven't woken up yet my subconscious
winds at me and a sneering mood again I
clear my throat trying Taylor who had
been retreating down the corridor turns
and heads back toward us are they based
at the University
Craster gray taylor asks when he reaches
us giving nothing away please can you
drive the photographer his assistants
miles as if it's a done deal
i frown um mr. greater this rule I'll
swap vehicles with Kate if you give me
Amal so I can go in I scoot around she
says with no preamble let's stop talking
by some miracle you take Wanda can I
take your car why
Christian Grey has asked me to go for
coffee with him the filmmakers have put
in effort to create actual escalation
this small change having Anna actually
want to go for coffee at least kinda
makes things look like some hot and cold
romantic tension the thing with the
books is that Anna constantly and I do
mean constantly mentally beats the crap
out of herself for the idea of liking
Christian and having any sort of sexual
ideas she is perpetually on the verge of
a complete meltdown like at the end of
the coffee scene which the filmmakers
have mercifully reworked into something
resembling human dialog Anna is almost
hit by a cyclist but is pulled out of
the way by Christian and then they look
into each other's eyes and he tells her
she should stay away from him because
they're no good for each other in the
film that's it
Anna looks a bit sad because I mean
she's just being pretty clearly rejected
but she walks away and goes about her
life we skipped to later in an otherwise
normal week in the book she goes into
the parking garage and has a complete
sobbing meltdown that leaves her curled
up in the fetal position on the concrete
what was I thinking
unbidden and unwelcome tears pool in my
eyes why am i crying I sink to the
ground angry at myself for this
senseless reaction drying up my knees I
fold in on myself I want to make myself
as small as possible adding this
stability to the character leads to some
of the film's best moments and some
legitimately fun and funny lines like
Anna and her friends go out drinking to
celebrate the end of their exams and
while standing in line for the washroom
Anna drunk dials Christian while on the
phone she quite accurately
mock's Christians behavior up to that
point listen to me I want you to go home
right now let's go for a coffee ana
let's go for coffee no stay away from me
Ana I know why you get away come here
come here go I said tell me where you
are it's great that's hilarious
this of course works because movie ana
is actually able to more or less
accurately read his emotional state
where book ana is confused by everything
now up to this point we're about twenty
two minutes into the movie the
filmmakers have done an admirable job of
massaging the story into something with
actual pacing and maybe a little less
nonsense within the constraint of not
being allowed to alter any plot points
unfortunately this scene is when they
run up against that as an inescapable
problem it's the big jump in the plot
that needed the most work to smooth it
over and they weren't allowed to touch
it so going off the broad template for
these types of stories we have our hot
and cold intro where the two characters
circle each other for a bit then the
first big break where they fall apart
and then something that brings them
crashing back into each other Gwen Hays
in her book romancing the beat how to
write kissing books calls this moment
adhesion because it doesn't just bring
the characters back together but is the
point that they get stuck that last
point can be really hard to come up with
in a satisfying way especially when the
characters are as is the case here from
two radically different worlds that
don't really intersect how do you get
the billionaire and the University
student back together how do you get
them to stay together it's challenging
so being in a situation where they were
forbidden from changing the plot point
the filmmakers had a choice do we keep
the detail about Christian hacking her
phone or not how did you find me I
tracked her cell phone
Anastasia oh of course he did how is
that possible is it legal stalker
my subconscious whispers at me through
the cloud of tequila that's still
floating in my brain but somehow because
it's him
I don't mind
yeah maybe a good skip there the scene
still has problems like Elliot just sort
of being invented out of nowhere
Kristian and Elliot being inside the bar
already stuff like that a lot changes
very quickly this is somewhat mitigated
in the movie because the cut from
standing in line for the washroom to
leaving the bar is a bit more ambiguous
where the book follows Anna through
every step in between and I'm pretty
sure Christian and Elliot get to the bar
faster than they should have been able
to get to the hotel's parking garage and
since we're at the bar okay we should
talk about Jose so the problem with Jose
is a problem that goes back to the very
beginning and I'm not talking about the
low-key racism the Dios mios or the fact
that Jose tries to molest Ana though you
know make note of all of those know what
we're talking about is the narrative
utility of Jose and how he fits or more
often fails to fit into the story here's
what Jose does in the books he's Anna
and Kate's friend though he's an
engineering major and not an English
major he does photography though mostly
architecture but gets press-ganged into
doing Christians head shots for Kate's
article because her normal photographer
isn't available after exams are done he
goes out drinking with Kate Nana tries
to get Ana super drunk then gropes her
in the parking lot before Christian
intervenes Marcell and Taylor Johnson
had the right idea that at this point
Jose's narrative utility if not his
friendship with Ana is done and he more
or less disappears for the rest of the
movie in the book he continues to float
around in the background and Ana's like
oh what's the little attempt at
date-rape between friends just don't do
it again
and he's always sort of there as though
he's going to form part of a love
triangle that never happens because he's
Jacob black and you can't just cut him
out of your fanfiction or Team Jacob
will revolt it's a little weird it's
just behind this door - like clear Oh
thank your xbox and stuff the dialogue
in the playroom is lifted straight out
of the book so of course it's all awful
I'm a dominant what does that mean it
means I want you to willingly surrender
yourself to me please weigh all the
scenes in the playroom are the scenes
that according to Sam taylor-johnson
Mitchell was most protective of
Christian does an awful job at pitching
the whole situation which kinda makes
sense given what his actual damages but
the problem is that we're not going to
learn that he's actually really bad at
the whole Dom thing until really far
into the next movie like okay it isn't
actually acknowledged until 842 pages
into the series I'm a sadist I like to
whip little brown haired girls like you
because you all look like the crack
[ __ ] my birth mother
even then that subject is going to be
more or less compartmentalize to a
single scene it's an element that's
never confronted so much as sidestepped
by having the characters never actually
engage in any meaningful SD interactions
beyond Anna's lightweight brat routine
the outcome of which is mostly light
bondage and a bit of spanking it's also
undercut by the whole thing where
Christian insists that he doesn't do
dates has never slept in the same bed as
someone else doesn't do romance and
flowers and lovemaking but he does he
took her out for coffee that's a date at
least they follow up this first playroom
scene with another substantial change
for the better when anna tells christian
that she's still a virgin
still a virgin
now this plot point is retained from the
book and it still feels kind of
fetishistic and is a bit off-putting for
that but how its responded to is
substantially better in the book
Christian stocks around the room running
his hands through his hair yelling and
growling and castigating Anna you're a
virgin I nod flushing again he closes
his eyes and looks to be counting to 10
when he opens them again he's angry
glaring at me why the [ __ ] didn't you
tell me Christian is running his hands
through his hair and pacing up and down
his study two hands that's double
exasperation his usual concrete control
seems to have slipped a notch I don't
understand why you didn't tell me he
castigates me the subject never came up
I'm not in the habit of revealing my
sexual status to everyone I meet I mean
we hardly know each other I'm staring at
my hands I am I feeling guilty why is he
so mad I peek up at him well you know a
lot more about me now he snaps his mouth
presses into a hard line I knew you were
inexperienced but a virgin he says it
like it's a really dirty word Marcel and
taylor-johnson on the other hand lay on
the mushy romance where have you been
waiting men must throw themselves
never what I wanted
this does however just further detail
that basic flaw in the telling of
Christians character Christian has spent
multiple scenes telling Anna all about
how he doesn't do romance doesn't do
flowers doesn't do dates first I don't
make love I [ __ ] hard but at a pin drop
he just decides some old-fashioned
lovemaking is in order so yeah I try not
to get in the habit of suggesting fixes
but it's really hard not to do that here
just have Anna be the one to escalate
once they start kissing I mean that's
the whole conflict here isn't it
Anna's moony-eyed romance verses
Christians business like dominance maybe
have a bit more push and pull with that
he gets her to try out some Spanky stuff
and she finds out she likes it he opens
up a bit to flowers and romance and
finds out it's not so bad either that
kinda is the big emotional arc here and
it is eventually acknowledged when
Christian agrees to a regular date night
once a week that or the record never
happens but maybe introduce that idea a
bit earlier than I don't know 260 pages
into the book but that's really an
unfair comparison because again in the
book version of this scene Christian is
stalking the room and yelling at Anna
and talks at length about how he's just
having sex with her to rectify her
virginity which he sees as a problem
so yeah I've never taken anyone in the
helicopter
I've never of sex in my own bed
I've never slept next to anyone when
they're walking out in the woods on the
way back to Portland this happens again
we're Christian tells Anna and us all
the things that he's done with Anna that
he's never done with anyone else like
taking them in the helicopter having sex
in his sleeping bed instead of his
designated sex bed having sex that was
outside the frame of a submission and
domination relationship but the impact
of that is undercut by the fact that
there hasn't really been any conflict
there there's no friction for Christian
he's not unsure of himself he's not lost
he enjoys it well enough so it's not a
character growth moment really he's just
describing the fact that yesterday he
experienced an incredibly banal first
ahna before yesterday I I'd never had
Boo Berry
before we always got Corn Pops and when
you put rooster sauce on the eggs I'd
never done that before either they were
okay so what this scene ends up doing
which I think almost works if you put
this first film in a bottle is it
emphasizes the Christians reticence to
compromise is pretty unreasonable it
still doesn't do that well but it does
do it this is an important contrast to
Anna who has stepped far more
dramatically outside her comfort zone
and found that she is for the most part
overwhelmed by the scope and intensity
of what Christian is asking far more
than any small part and again it needs
to be highlighted that Christian really
isn't presented as breaking through any
significant hurdles there is no conflict
leading up to Christian asking Anna out
for coffee there's no panic attack about
wanting to take a romantic interest
flying in his helicopter it's effortless
there's a lot of nuanced argument over
the idea of show don't tell like we can
come up with all kinds of examples we're
just telling the audience what's going
on is actually pretty effective and then
we could get into further debate over
whether or not those examples are still
supported or themselves support visual
or environmental evidence that shows the
thing we were being told and thus it's
all a combination of showing and telling
but this right here
Christian Grey just saying it's a big
deal that he's never had
in his sleeping bed instead of his sex
bed this right here is the poster child
for the kind of limp storytelling that
leads to getting your writing back from
the editor with show don't tell
written in big red letters in the margin
we are told that this is a conflict that
this is all outside Christians comfort
zone but that conflict is supported by
absolutely nothing else as a result this
point ends up falling into a hazy space
where it's not a satisfying parallel
between the two characters because the
stakes are so disproportionate but it's
also not just cute banter because
there's clearly supposed to be weight to
it in the cinematic language this is the
culmination of a scene where Christian
tells Anna the first inkling of his dark
past and admits that he's still friends
with the woman who raped him when he was
a teenager the characters are framed at
a past dead end on the edge of dark
water Anna is trapped visually in the
noisy chaotic half of the frame with
Christian acting as the barrier between
a cage and freedom the soundtrack is
tense kind of sinister visually the
color palette of the scene gets colder
as the scene progresses when they walk
down the path the highlights are warm at
the docks they're neutral and when we
come in for the close-up they're cool
and muted the scene is emotionally and
literally getting darker but for what
this is the kind of moment that
encapsulates why this movie stuck with
me in the way it did moments of talented
subtle filmmaking in the service of
material that just does it no justice
the biggest example of this is the
negotiation earlier we discussed how the
middle of the book is a mess lots of
disjointed chapters repeated scenes
fragmented developments and awful stuff
this is where they managed to sort most
of that out the scene is an amalgamation
of mostly chapters 13 and 15 two of the
worst in the book I say worst because
there are a couple of the scenes where
we get the clearest example of Christian
just absolutely disregarding Anna's
agency comfort and explicit wishes in
the first a dinner meeting Anna
explicitly asks that they stay in public
for the conversation and Christian
immediately
her to a private dining room I think we
should stay in public on neutral ground
he smiles sardonic Lee do you think that
would stop me he says softly a sensual
warning my eyes widen and I swallow
again I hope so
come I have a private dining room booked
no public in the second the actual meat
and potatoes negotiation Christian keeps
pressing Anna to drink more
despite Anna being a lightweight let's
not go too far we know your capacity for
alcohol is limited anastasia he picks up
the champagne takes off the foil top and
cage twist the bottle rather than if he
fills my cup is he giving me tipsy
aye-aye him suspiciously he glances
quickly at me more my keys and I drink
practically all of it in my cup again
more he asks more my brain is beginning
to fog hmm did you give me tipsy on
purpose yes why because you overthink
everything
and you're reticent like your stepdad a
drop of wine in you and you start
talking and I need you to communicate
honestly with me otherwise you clam up
and I have no idea what you're thinking
in vino veritas
Anastasia nothing freaks me out more
than people who say this is about
domestic abuse yeah anyway the
filmmakers have pulled all of the
negotiations stuff together into a
single scene that really gives us an
idea of what things maybe could have
looked like in an alternate universe
where Mitchell had less control over the
project it's witty it's sassy it's fun
there's a cute power play between the
characters this is part of the overall
trend of imbuing movie Anna with more
agency and awareness she isn't getting
under his skin by accident she's
deliberately flirting find anal fisting
I'm all ears
strike it out
strike out vaginal fisting to be sure
yeah it also ties into the changes to
Christian Anna isn't afraid of what he's
going to do how he's going to respond
she's not worried that she's making him
angry it creates a much needed dramatic
moment where it looks like things might
actually work out that they'll be able
to reach a proper compromise before
everything starts to fall apart again
this is the midpoint the faults high and
for the most part this scene works in
its own little bubble I mean out of the
bubble it's a complete waste because
despite the fact that they have this
whole negotiation where Anna gets
basically all the concessions that she
wants and then in the next scene at her
graduation she tells Christian yes she
still doesn't physically sign the
contract and it becomes something that
they argue about on and off for the rest
of the book slash movie because both do
a really poor job at distinguishing
between kinky sex which is what they
still do and the full on 24/7 total
package dom sub lifestyle that christian
wants and this is where the movie
actually stumbles counter-intuitively
getting less coherent by being better
like okay it still doesn't make sense in
the book what the actual stakes are
because the two of them are just
endlessly arguing about nothing but that
kind of gets worse in the movie because
the movie versions of the characters are
at least nominally capable of having an
honest and open conversation about their
relationship
so changing it to be a scene where anna
is sober and professional and gets
christian to make numerous compromises
but never addresses the punishment angle
actually makes less sense than a scene
where Christian gets Anna drunk and
steamrolls her opinions with a few minor
concessions but still the lighting works
the timing works the acting works Danny
Elfman's score is at its most Danny
Elfman
eroticism is used to build the
characters and tell the story which is
not what can be said for about 90% of
the sex in both the book and the movie I
think the scenes in Fifty Shades are
well shot they're well lit they're well
scored and they managed to convey an
engaging level of eroticism so they're
at least trashy fun but there's a deeper
problem where they fail to work as
scenes almost all of them can be cut
from the film and leave little impact
with their absence this actually makes a
lot of sense if we go all the way back
and review the origins of the text
master of the universe as you'll recall
was originally published on
fanfiction.net which has a prohibition
on sexually explicit content how
effective that prohibition has
historically being is up for debate but
regardless Erika Mitchell worked around
it by posting saucy versions of the
story there and more explicit versions
to her personal website so if it seems
like the characters do all their
relevant character talking and then stop
to have sex that these sex scenes are a
post hoc addition to the actual story
it's because they are this is all just a
roundabout way of getting around to
talking about the end of the film so
when the film was in production the
second and third films had not
technically been greenlit yet there were
contracts securing principal creatives
in the event of the second and third
films being made but Fifty Shades of
Grey went into production with the
possibility that it would be the only
adaptation actually made I know it seems
silly to think that Paramount would only
make one of the books into a movie in a
post Harry Potter Hunger Games world but
also consider that while Fifty Shades
rise to fame had been Swift there was
always the possibility that it would
fade just as quickly if you buy the film
rights in 2013 for a book that had only
really been out for a year and a half
how sure are you that audiences will
still be around in for five years by the
time darker and freed were greenlit gray
was already deep into post-production I
bring it up because it places unique
creative pressure on the director and
screenwriter who now need to try and
craft a movie that will work both as a
potential standalone film and as the
first act of a three-part series with
that as foreplay let's talk about the
final scene in the playroom the belt
whipping scene alright so something
vague has gone wrong with Christians
vague business stuff in the book I think
it's that one of Christians cargo boats
with relief aid food bound for Africa is
sunk by pirates or something and he's
sunk into a deep funk over this Anna
tries to sex him back to happiness by
letting him tie her up and blindfold her
but it doesn't work because it's not
extreme enough so he's sitting up late
at night playing sad piano the two of
them have a very confusing argument
about the contract that anna has agreed
to but not signed that ultimately kind
of revolves around the fact that anna
really just doesn't like the idea of
punishment this is actually where a lot
of kenkon BDSM enthusiasts take the most
umbrage because of the specific dominant
submissive interaction of rules and
punishments and rewards is where Erika
Mitchell basically says that if people
enjoy those kinds of games it's because
they're emotionally damaged it's a way I
am either way the conversation gets more
confusing when Christian insists that
the contract is still in force in spirit
even though she didn't sign it and if
she acts out there will be punishment
and so anna says okay fine show me how
bad it can get and Christian brings her
into the playroom and tells her he's
going to whip her with a belt six times
now I want to reiterate something I said
earlier from a story standpoint it's
okay if Christian is a bit of a bastard
because it gives the characters
something to conflict over just
something needs to come of it one of the
things that Sam taylor-johnson wanted to
do with this scene was have Anna use her
safe word red while Christian keeps
going and that is actually a brilliant
change or it would have been if it had
happened it properly centers the
conflict around Christians actual
character flaws it calls attention to
his selfishness makes his disregard for
Anastasia's well-being explicit and
gives Anna a very very good reason to
leave the relationship immediately
it is an overt betrayal of her trust it
says that Christian thinks he's in
control but ultimately lacks the
self-control to restrain himself it
points out that his love of rules is
ultimately a shallow facade to justify
his very mundane abuse that right there
shows us the thing that Mitchell is
going to try to tell us in the next book
I like to whip little brown haired girls
like you it would have been a great
change and Erica Mitchell lost her mind
reports from set are that this dialogue
change triggered an hour-long shouting
match in front of cast and crew until
ultimately Mitchell got her way the
scene as included in the movie plays out
pretty much exactly the same as it does
in the book where Ana takes the whipping
and then freaks out because she can't
quite process that Christian likes the S
& M parts of BDSM anyway Sam
taylor-johnson and Kelly Marcel are far
better storytellers than Erica Mitchell
and they understand Mitchell's story
better than she does as evidenced by the
closing moments of the film where Ana
goes to leave Cristian moves to
intercept her and she tells him no stop
no
of course that would play a million
times better if the story had actually
been about boundaries but as it is it
still plays as part of an artistically
strong final scene culminating in the
fantastic final shot of the theatrical
edition the Unrated edition as a sad
montage is that is weaker as a
standalone film but ties into fifty
shades darker a bit more naturally again
that challenge of making a film that
will work as both it's kind of the
bottom line here the film is
surprisingly well made with a deliberate
artfulness for a movie that still
ultimately isn't very good its watchable
and it has its distinct highlights and
craft and skill there are scenes and
moments that are good even great but the
whole is still less than the sum of its
parts
undercut by fundamentally flawed source
material and with all that conclusion of
video bloody block closing statements
we're going to keep going with this
that's right we're not done we've got
two more of these suckers to get through
and it's all downhill from here oh yeah
just you wait some stuff to look forward
to when we talk about darker Sam
taylor-johnson and Kelly Marcel getting
fired for you know trying to make the
movie better the serial thickness
ramping up to high gear the budget cuts
the helicopter crash the stalkers why do
you have my bank account details online
heads don't automatically translate to
print sales well but they could the
right term is a sadist I get off and
punishing women women who look like you
mother reporter Rachel Taylor Rachel
thank you John I'm speaking to you live
from the private helicopter terminal
Bailey have been found safe and well and
are at this moment on their way back to
see a
what the hell are y'all doing here oh
boy
[Music]